what is going on there reject nation
greg john and coy john drew is with us
today how are you guys doing what's
going on i'll tell you what's going on
okay coy and i were responsible adults
that went to bed around 11 45 11 30 pm
set the phone in airplane mode and then
bam apparently this trailer came out at
midnight we discovered it at 4 45 a.m
the heartbreak
heartbreak i felt you have no idea how
long i've been trying to get koi to come
on this channel i'm like dude they
usually come in at six to show up at 5
45. we got this man the reason i really
wanted koi for a marvel one is this koi
is undoubtedly the biggest marvel nut i
know if you guys haven't seen his series
comic book shopping here's just a few of
the guests that he has worked with i'm
telling you this guy knows comics better
than anyone else i know in l.a i think
jon would have tested that as well and
to give john credit he did catch us at
midnight why were you not asleep we
planned for fun
but guys follow koi on social media he
is here with us at 5 30 in the morning
follow his own solo youtube channel
let's get into this
[Music]
hey jack
five years ago thomas erased half of the
population of the universe
the people of this planet brought
everyone back the snap of a finger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you better explain everything built the
world in seven days religious allegories
and celestial is very smart
another seven
okay
there we go there we go
[Music]
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this looks so beautiful
dude
wow
oh i love i love how this looks
[Laughter]
it's good to know the inventor of the
team still shops at the best i mean
that's where you shop that's where you
shop
puts it together faster than us
too much work man go to ikea
cosines ikea you know
all right i really love that trailer a
lot john are gonna give super quick
thoughts as we talk plenty about the
eternals ready and then we're gonna let
coy kick a bunch of ass okay
so
i thought like this trailer was um even
better than the last one because we
really get a sense for the scope we
really get a sense for the scale this
one felt like a lot more of the marvel
qualities that we want like the deviants
look really threatening i love how
menacing and harrowing like the peril
you can really feel that on display here
it was cool to get a sense of like
pretty much everyone's powers this time
around i love the use of the visual
effects combined mainly with a bunch of
like a shooting on location practical
stuff as well yeah i thought this was a
really really great trailer because i
remember the teaser i had a feeling of
this looks really cool but the the
production design around the characters
have this bit of like i feel like
they're semi cosplaying to a certain
extent because the sets didn't really uh
feel alive even though i love that they
were shooting on location this
completely took it in the other
direction where i'm like oh never mind
okay i take that all back
this is awesome like i really like that
first trailer but this one i especially
love john take it away yeah i would
agree with you this one seemed like it
had a bit more room to breathe a bit
more room to expand on what we saw in
the first trailer and i love that
caliber that they're eluding at here
where yeah we did go to all these
locations we are using big cgi but we're
not relying on that for everything and
it does feel like chloe zhao is able to
bring the sense of gravitas you would
expect from getting an oscar-winning
director to your first oscar winning
director to do an mcu movie so yeah this
was one of those trailers where like
every shot is so picturesque and
breathtaking and it really got me kind
of mood that i think this movie's trying
to pitch up this larger-than-life
scopic adventure that does also directly
account for why they haven't been
interfering and what they were doing
while things was around and all that so
this was really exciting they're
actually addressing the comments
absolutely koi my man watch what koi
does take it away go comic bookie on us
do it buddy
so what i'm fascinated by is they're
leaning deeply into the religious
overtones we haven't had a movie with
this kind of texture before using the
film stock and the full flavor of what
she's built they're also not shying away
from very dense subject matter it's
talking about creation they're talking
about seven days they're talking about
destruction there's a lot of religious
overtones there with you know god
creating the world in seven days the
celestials creating all these things
that i think are very specific and using
that in a trailer is really bold because
you're showing the audience like hey
this isn't gonna be a marvel movie that
you can just casually pop in kick back
enjoy you've got a cast the sexiest cast
i think yes we've seen quite some time
we're talking dune and knight's tale
level sexy and they're all at the height
of their powers we're talking about
people that are beyond gods these are
characters that are gonna make thanos
look
very middling also i can almost
guarantee you thanos pops up to show
their power set thanos is a deviant in
his own right he's a titan he's related
to all these people he's actually
technically related to angelina jolie's
character in the canon of the comic
books her name's her name
sorry interrupt please go i mean by all
means so she be related i think there's
going to be an element of power
structure we're going to see how strong
they are as related to thanos and i
can't believe just in our world we got
to see selma hack say the word thanos
that just like that experience for me as
a movie nerd and comic nerd but i really
appreciate the fact that they gave us a
celestial at the jump 30 seconds into
the trailer we all had the reaction of
the scope that they wanted to portray i
think that nymax is really going to show
people what cosmic marvel can be with
guardians of the galaxy it it cracked
the door open to what we can experience
and then through loki and more this
phase 4 stuff we're about to experience
mind-bending reality bending
consciousness in a way that's going to
make us undermine our own perception of
the first three phases in a way that you
can kind of rewrite everything we've had
to this point you can retroactively make
things canon through what if you can
retroactively make things work through
this this god mode we're entering with
this world and we can explain any plot
points including the x-men fantastic
four by this creation of half the people
coming back through that energy that
tidal wave shot all of that to me read
we're getting x-men fantastic four and a
lot of seeds planted here i'm not saying
that by the end of the movie we've got
those characters i am saying that by the
end of the movie something will have
happened to cause a throwback in a
future movie to say like oh this is when
the seed was planted gotcha wow that was
amazing that's what i think don't really
have to jump cut that one
i really appreciate that
i've ever seen
in the morning
also worth noting eternals are one of
the densest comic books and something i
know maybe the least about
so as far as the comic book awareness
they're a character set that are popping
in and out of the comic books through
the decades and it's always like a
writer gets a hold of them writes his
arc and then goes
ah
and then they just like kind of faded
the distance so much like in the movie
there's an awareness of like they exist
but they're only here when we need them
and in the comics it's very similar it's
like we're gonna go into the darkness
for a while and right now there's a
really beautiful run uh illustrated by
assad ruby and it is stunning in its
depth of field and it's inking and it
looks like chloe xiao's like
cinematography they're actually
mirroring the line work of her film work
in the line work of the comic book so it
feels immersive in both mediums do you
have any theories at all about any of
the characters like i'm feeling like
icarus might actually be a bag i think
you're just a bad guy i think you're
accuracy i'm getting bad guy vibes can
we also note that richard madden was
like everyone's fan cast for cyclops
it could still happen multiple realities
and uh what did you think about the
deviants um i liked the deviants but i
definitely need more to really know if
they're gonna feel like um space dogs
there is a part of me that goes like i
remember the incredible hulk when you
[ __ ] gamma dogs like i just i need to
know that there's going to be a texture
to them that feels like something beyond
what we've seen so far this is the first
trailer don't show me more please stop
yeah but at this point this is uh this
was the story trailer this was for
people like me to go like that's
referencing this this and this and for
people in you know
out of the pop culture sphere to get to
know enough that they're like i'm in or
not because i think the first trailer
like you were saying was just hey this
is the palette we're playing with yeah
like it just showed us the colors this
was them showing us what colors were
painting with in action this was like
page one of the coloring book now i
don't want more now please give me no
more story please don't show me the
final trailer actually good all right
koi um we gotta bring them on for every
we need get ready
this is the one i know the least
imagine what happens
that's captain america
oh man
i know that like the back of my hand
let's do this safe to say you gotta
subscribe to koi janju's channel please
check him out on social media i
appreciate you being an energetic
trooper at this time of day you could
subscribe to us we bring on people like
that's what we're here for
uh hit that like button tell us your
thoughts about the eternals seriously
that was uh i really am happy you're
here we gotta do another video later
today okay and we'll catch you guys soon
coy desperately wanted to get a thought
i had a thought okay so dane whitman is
very very clearly our eye line as the
audience he's the human of the cast he's
gonna be in the love triangle there's
gonna be three people in love he's gonna
be our eye line to it but it's really
smart to have him be the one that
addresses the plot point why haven't
they been helping what have they been
doing he's gonna be our guy to guide us
through the plot he's gonna be a lot of
exposition and then in the post-credits
scene he's gonna turn the black knight i
don't think it's black knight until the
third act or the post-credits team
because that earns our eyeline our
hero's journeys through dane whitman
thank you very much jon so knows nothing
but he will he will
[Music]